I'm supposed to be a genius or something
look one two three four five hi I'm Mike
Seymour from FX guide.com for wired with
half a billion dollars in its opening
weekend the park is very much open for
business Jurassic world is said to be
the biggest film of the summer as the
name would suggest we're back amongst
the dinosaurs with ILM delivering both
old friends and some new pretty evil
enemies to get the subtle performances
eylem decided to go heavily into motion
capture which is kind of an unusual
choice given the size and shape but say
the Raptors when you typically use
motion capture to add realism but the
performance artist couldn't even
physically stand the way a raptor does
for any length of time if you really
dealt with it from a company side as big
as ILM where you can you can do a lot of
noodling afterwards on it get things to
work what is the advantage of motion
capture you know is there is even is
there what well there is and this
complexity of the motion you can get far
more stuff going on and could ever be
animated by a great animator and you can
do it for many shots with many
characters it'll give it a look you
haven't seen before I think it's really
set a bar a new bar a higher standard
and when I see the dailies honest like I
have not seen anything like this before
you know they look like they're heavy
they look if you have a life to them
they you know the skin is actually
moving over the bones and the bones are
moving onto the skin what's most
impressive is how Islands team managed
to retarget the motion capture
performances to these vastly differently
shaped models and not losing the process
the subtlety and the high-frequency
detail of the original performances we
actually cast four people here that were
the Raptors so every time we need to do
blue this person would show up so in
terms of the retargeting you know each
person kind of leaned over a little bit
differently or put their arms and slow
a different position and knowing that
person how to retarget that to that
particular Raptor was really keen to add
to this work of the animators and motion
capture artists on top of that there's a
very detailed and extremely important
layer of time-consuming complex flesh
simulations which give the especially
indominus rex believable movement well
believable for a genetically engineered
camouflaging 40-foot long hybrid
dinosaur hunter don't forget subscribe
for more behind the scenes action I
might see more for wide
you